para algunos sheryl sandberg es la mujer
más poderosa de la tecnología y su
salida de la dirección de meta marca el
fin de una era según el fundador de
facebook por encima de todo le estoy
agradecido por todo lo que ha hecho por
construir meta
sheryl sandberg se graduó en harvard
trabajó para el banco mundial para la
consultoría mckenzie y para google
cuando llego a facebook en 2008 la
empresa no era rentable por lo que se la
considera responsable del éxito
económico y comercial de la compañía
tecnológica meta es una de las
corporaciones más poderosas del planeta
alcanzó un volumen de negocio de 118 mil
millones de dólares y un beneficio de 39
mil millones en 2021
está claro que la señora sandberg ha
jugado un papel determinante en el auge
de facebook y ahora de meta
deja un claro legado al construir esta
infraestructura que ha convertido a la
empresa en la segunda mayor vendedora de
publicidad del planeta
una red social convertida en máquina
publicitaria los métodos de sheryl
sandberg no están exentos de polémica el
grupo californiano es criticado por sus
prácticas de recolección de datos
personales por otro lado me estás sufre
una crisis de crecimiento frente a la
competencia precisamente en un mensaje
de facebook la directora de operaciones
reveló su partida
cuando empecé este trabajo en 2008
esperaba quedarme cinco años en este
puesto 14 años más tarde es momento de
escribir un nuevo capítulo en mi vida
un nuevo capítulo consagrado a proyectos
filantrópicos y a defender el lugar de
las mujeres en el mundo de la tecnología
sin embargo sheryl sandberg continuará
en el consejo de administración de meta